i don't remember seeing the pilot you
don't remember seeing the pilot i know
what the pilot is right but i don't know
where i was and when i saw it i don't
but you got to remember like the first
time you watched an episode of
smallville that you were the lead in it
and thought you had different you get
thoughts about it i just don't remember
when or where i was but i do remember
when clark pulls off in the pilot when
he pulls off the door to the truck
and he says uh
you know my name's clark kent you're in
smallville
i remember doing that scene and being
like oh this is awesome
like this is this is like james bond
indiana jones it's like there was just
so much about that moment you know um
i just remember
when we were doing it i remember being
i remember it being cool yeah you were
so young so i i mean you
also you didn't have time to go home and
study lines
no now that's got to be terrifying sort
of for someone
like me
who always studied lines and did plays
and you know had to really learn the
stuff so i could be free on set but you
you just didn't have the time you're in
every scene every day you could you had
to go home and sleep but that was my job
my job was to be there all the time
every day um
as you know with clark and lex but clark
doesn't have a lot of lines and a lot of
times in television shows the leads
don't because the story needs to be
you know they're in the middle of the
story so this you know everybody else
talks to them it's a lot at the times
what happens in television shows um
so like
you know you and i would be in scenes
and i'd be like man this guy you know
you got a ton of lines like it's you you
you and then right clark would be like
what do you mean
but my job was to be there all the time
innocent and and i always
you know for 10 years my life it was
whatever it takes to be there that's
just was my focus did you ever have
breaking points where you're like i
can't freaking do this i'm i'm so tired
they've got to give me a day off um did
you ever have moments where you're
driving to work and you're just like i
got to pull over i'm so tired i mean
i've got to be honest with you that was
most days
like it was most days because we drove
ourselves to work yeah until the cast
got together yeah and said tom
driver he's going to die yeah he's going
to die he's your lead role he's our lead
guy
you so many times you were driving to
work and you had to pull over
i i i got pulled over once
by a cop by a cop
um i was going to work i was just in a
constant like irritated mood all the
time and i remember one day i was
driving to work like season three
and it was like
i'm sure some of some of you listening
are watching this
a car is slowed in front of you you want
to just not slow down
you hit the horn
the car clears and you realize like
someone just got in an accident there's
a cop already there and the cop just
turned to me and was like turn up like
so i pulled over and then i was like
what are you honking for and
in vancouver honking your horn
canadians don't honk they don't wants
so they're canadians they're lovely and
i'm not a big honker but it was just
that moment i was like
oh
and he's what are you hoping for i'm
like i just
i'm he and he he made me sit there for a
minute to almost teach me like
calm down slow down never give me a
ticket but i you know i mean i needed to
hear that right there yeah like just
chill out a little bit dude but you were
absolutely you'd say
at least once or twice a week on the way
to work or on the way home you're just
like i'm out of my mind tired yeah
constantly like did you fall asleep easy
did you ever need any pills to go to
sleep never pills never
a beer what i did is i would normally
nap for 15 minutes at lunch like
i would
like during lunch
i would have i would get my lunch eat it
while i was walking get to my trailer
lay down
15 minutes later get up and the second
part of my day was always more
productive i felt right just from a nap
you know harry truman used to nap he
said just in a box of shorts a pair of
boxers and a t-shirt and take a little
30-minute power nap and it used to make
his day that's what he did i still love
naps